what i try to do is just try to be still
and understand that things come and go
emotions come and go the important thing
is to
accept them all to embrace them all
and then you can choose to do with them
which you want
versus being controlled by emotion
you know a lot of times i've seen
players even myself you know when i was
younger
being consumed by a particular fear um
and to the point where you're saying
okay nah it's not good to feel fear
i shouldn't be nervous in a situation
like not and it does nothing but grow
versus stepping back and saying yeah i
am nervous about this situation
yeah i am fearful about the situation
but what am i afraid of and then you
kind of
unpack it and then it gives you the
ability to look at it for really what it
is which is
nothing more than your imagination
running its course you know
yeah absolutely i love that because what
you're saying is that when you're
dealing with something it's almost like
how can i get to the root of it
yeah because sometimes what we're
dealing with like you're saying it's an
imagination an illusion it's not really
it's not it's not really a thing yeah
you know like you think about
game-winning shots and
or game-winning free throws and people
go to the free-throw line and they're
nervous about it what are you really
nervous about if you unpack that okay
you're
nervous that you're gonna miss the shot
all right so you missed the shot then
what happens people are gonna be
embarrassed you're gonna be embarrassed
because thousands of people millions of
people see you missed a shot
all right and then what people want to
talk bad about you
okay right and so you're looking at it
go are those things even
important you know what i mean if that
that is my fear like
what is you worried about letting your
teammates down okay have you let them
down before well i'm sure and practice
and things of that nature right they're
still there
yeah you know and so when you're able to
unpack it you kind of look at it for
what it is which is really nothing
i think the best way to prove your your
value is to work
is to learn is to absorb
to be a sponge but you always want to
outwork
your potential you know as hard as you
believe you can work
you can work harder than that and that's
what i try to do when i first came in
the league but you know basketball is
such a direct competition sport that me
coming in at 17 i
hated when like my teammates would say
you know i get hit with an elbow right
shaq would hit me with elbow in practice
and like
you know you know nick van exel will
come up and say are you okay
what am i are you okay
the hell is wrong with you you know so
like i always had that extra chip on my
shoulder so like every day in practice
for me was
really trying to annihilate everybody
that was that i was playing against
so i wanted to prove you don't need to
babysit me
like i'm fine you know and uh
and so it's always that competitive
nature
the work ethic and curiosity because i
asked a lot of questions
you know playing with byron scott i
asked him a lot of questions eddie jones
who was great at chasing guards off the
screens and i didn't understand how to
do that
i would sit with him before practice
after practice
magic james worthy kurt rambis
kareem abdul all the laker greats i
would always sit down and just ask them
questions
about certain games that i studied
growing up what actually happened there
what did you feel there
why you know very tough to defend why
because you look slower
than me i'm like i'm missing something
so like tell me what i'm missing you
know what i mean
and so i would always ask questions and
try to learn as much as i could
do you have a mindfulness or meditative
practice that you used while you played
yeah well phil introduced meditation to
us when he came
to our team in 99 2000 and
it was something that i instantly
gravitated to because i could see
the effects right you and i used to
watch
you know studying the games the bulls
teams
and um you know watching their demeanor
watching their composure
playing in a tough place in like utah
doing the finals and being down
but everybody was like this you couldn't
tell if they were down 17 or up
20 or tie game it never changed
and i was wondering why the hell that is
and that's why i started doing more
research and when phil came
i immediately gravitated to it and found
myself
accepted the challenge of finding what
that space is and
for the 81 point game and to be honest i
was i wasn't even thinking about the
game my knee was hurting so much
i didn't know then but you know i had to
flap a joint
of cartilage stuck in my joint line and
so my mind was really trying to
go to a place where i don't feel that
pain
and game started and because of that
i was just in a different space i wasn't
worried about
what was to come i wasn't worried about
what just happened i was just here
and when you're just there in the moment
playing plays right in front of you your
focus is heightened
because nothing else matters um
and that's the space i've tried to get
to i've been with you
for a long way i i the one moment that
stands out
out of we've done i don't know how many
done we've done what 800 events
the one time was 4 we went out to
practice at 4 00 a.m
and that was your idea to do it but and
then you know all these nike people are
like no no
no let's not let's not do that and then
you're like let's do it at 4 00 a.m so
you got security you got brand marketing
sports marketing going no
no no no no that's not good you're like
let's do it because that's your
assessment
right i mean to me it just makes
complete sense not to us
but i don't like see we all right
usually i'm sleeping at 4am you're here
working
out so talk about that okay so if if
if your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be
right to do that you have to practice
you have to train right
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can
so if you get up at 10 in the morning
train at 11
right 12 say 12 train at 12 train for
two hours 12 to two
um you have to let your body recover so
you eat recover whatever you get back
out
you train start training again at six
train from six to eight
right and now you go home you shower you
eat dinner you go to bed you wake up you
do it again right those are two sessions
right now imagine you wake up at three
you train at four go four to six
come home breakfast relax
now you're back at it again nine to 11
right relax and now it's done you're
back at it again two to four
and now you're back at it again you know
seven to nine
look how much more training i have done
by simply starting at four
right so now you do that and as the
years go on
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers
just grows larger and larger and larger
and larger and larger
and by year five or six doesn't matter
what kind of work they do in the summer
they're never going to catch up
because they're five years behind right
so it makes sense to get up and start
your day early because you can get more
working
is that genetic or is that something you
you ingrained and trained yourself no it
was just taught you that for me it was
it was just common sense like i can i
can if i start earlier i can train more
hours
and i know the other guys aren't doing
it because i know what their training
schedule is
right so i know if i do this
consistently over time
this the gaps just going to widen and
wide and wide and why and why
and they won't be able to get that back
so it to me it was just common sense and
like thinking how can i get an advantage
oh
start earlier yeah let's do that how do
you develop that or where do you
what do you learn that from well i i
think it's just
you know it's just a matter of what's
important to you
and what's important to you for for
whatever reason
you know i felt like i didn't feel
good about myself if i wasn't doing
everything i could
to be the best version of myself if i
felt like i left anything on the table
um it would eat away at me i wouldn't be
able to look myself in the mirror
right so the reason why i can retire now
and be completely comfortable about it
because i know that i've done
everything i could to be the best
basketball player i could be
um and so that's where it comes from for
me
you can't leave any stone unturned i had
a summer where i played basketball
when i was like 10 or 11 years old and a
very prominent
summer league in philadelphia called the
sunny hillbilly where my father played
my uncle played and they were like
all-time greats yeah
stuff and will chamberlain played in the
league you know uh
early pro monroe playing league and here
i come
playing and i don't score one point the
entire summer
really not one how old were you 11 10
11.
you're playing against other 10 11 year
olds or you need to score once not one
were you in the game i was in a game
how did you not score because i was
terrible really yeah
that happened 11 years old you were that
awful i mean i you know and i had these
big knee pads on because i was
growing really fast i had socks all the
way up here and i had like the
high like skinny as hell
and i scored not a free throw not a
nothing not a lucky shot not a breakaway
layup
zero points is that when you think the
mentality of hard work
started to come in for you at that age
when you failed
so miserably i guess that summer i think
that's when the idea of
understanding a long-term view became
important
because i wasn't going to catch these
kids in a week i wasn't going to catch
them in a year
right so that's when i sat down and said
okay this is going to take some thought
all right what i want to work on first
all right shooting all right let's knock
this out let's focus on this half a year
six months do nothing but shoot
right after that all right creating your
own shot and you focus so you start i
started creating a menu of things
when i came back the next summer i was a
little bit better right yeah immediately
like i've got my jump shot from 15
i've got yeah i got my jump shot from 15
i got my three-point shot like just
open shots not miss open shots right be
able to shoot it with speed because
those kids are so much more athletic
yeah
and then the next time i came back was a
little better the summer came back
next summer i was a little better i
scored yeah it wasn't much right but i
scored and this is 12 13
12 13. then 14 came around back half of
13 14
years old and then i was just killing
everyone
and it happened in two years and i
wasn't expected to happen in two years
but it did
because what i had to do was work on the
basics and the fundamentals
but they relied on athleticism and their
natural ability
and because i stick to the fundamentals
it just caught up to them
and then my body you know my knees
stopped hurting i grew into my frame
and then your athleticism once you have
the fundamentals exactly
the hard work the mindset and you attack
on the elections
wow so from 13 you're
good average still i was good i was good
and then about about
like the end of my third like right when
i was turning 14
i became the best player in the state at
14 and 14. so from 12 to 14 you went
from scoring zero to being the best in
the state
of all ages yeah there was a year there
in 03
where i had 40 points in nine straight
games
right shaq was out it was a toad
thing so phil comes to me before the
stresses kobe we need you to take over
the offense
i'm like all right cool so that's no
more i got it
i got it so that literally started the
streak
a 40 straight game you know 40 points in
nine straight games
shaq comes back from injury and phil
goes you know i still continue to do it
right and then phil
calls me to his office goes hey you know
we're starting to lose the big fellow
what do you mean well he's not getting
the attention you know this this
40-point
streak is starting to kind of take away
his fire
to prove something right so i need you
to start dialing it back
i'm like what he says
we're going to lose them and we need
them in june
okay all right we have a game against
the clippers
i got like 38 or something like that and
a chance to score 40 and to get 40 again
it's a blowout game like
dump the ball in the shack instead of
shooting wide open shot the 40-point
streak ended that night
wow that was it and that's inside stuff
that people don't know
right are you happy
yeah cause phil was like hey we gotta
dial it back gotta dial it back we're
starting to lose the big fella perfect
kobe too you're like he's like you gotta
dial it back you're like all right i'll
score 38 instead of 40.
well i mean it's the streak thing i
wouldn't it would have been 10 in a row
broke a record right
right right would have broke the record
but instead you know the passion came
from the love for the game
you know i loved everything about it
like the smell of the ball
you love the smell of the ball yes the
ball you know the smell of like brand
new sneakers and like the sound the ball
makes when it hits the ground
sneakers in the gym yeah the ball going
through the net like all those things
i love and so the passion comes from
that because once you have that love you
just want to
be a part of this thing all the time is
there one moment where you can say
it define your passion for basketball is
there a story or moment when you said
yeah that was
that was it that was like when i felt
really passionate
no it doesn't it never leaves it never
leaves like
you know the game is just a part of me
um so it never leaves even now
that i'm retired you know everything
i've learned from the game of basketball
i've carried it over into life
you know like basketball's helped me be
a better person a better friend a better
house
well because there's life lessons that
are within the game like communication
like unselfishness like attention to
detail
and um empathy and compassion like all
those things are in the game
and uh as an athlete if we are aware of
those things
it helps us become better human human
beings
and you can apply that toward your post
post basketball days retirement into
your business world
future ventures sure i mean you can play
you know i was applying that
um even while i was playing just in life
outside of the game
and even more so now you know in
building a business and all these things
you know the kind of culture you want to
have
you know all those things are
directly learned from the game of
basketball
was it a hard decision like i'm going
pro or did you just know because a rod
obviously did the same thing
yeah um you know as a young kid 17
18 going to be a pro athlete it was uh
it was a tough decision i i
you know ultimately
the key factor for me was wasn't whether
or not i was ready
it was the fact that if i wasn't ready i
was determined to figure out how to get
ready
and ultimately even if i was ready
i still need to improve anyway right so
the work's not going to stop
it was just a matter of do you want to
come to the league and learn from the
best and i'm doing the math in my head
i'm looking at
stockton how many years he's playing
drexler how many years he's playing
mj how many years more he's playing
hakeem these are players that i studied
growing up
and the best way to learn from them is
to have that jump off of the film
jump off of the page and see it face to
face
that's the best way to learn because i
had it was like a database i had
everything in my mind and what they
could do what they didn't like to do
where they did it when they did it
now if i could see that up close that is
the greatest form of education that i
could possibly receive
so that's when i was like nah i'm gonna
i'm gonna go pro you have a brand you
have a shoe
um but you've chosen to do something
else something
that's that's more bold something that
you really haven't done before
can you tell us why you're doing this
why you're going into a creative
endeavor like granity studios
um because i love doing it i mean it's
that simple
you know you have to sit and ask
yourself what is truly going to get you
up in the morning it's going to keep you
up at night
and you know when you find what that
answer is you stay true to that
you know i've built a brand for the last
20 some years personal brand which is
great
but that is not where our focus is going
to be for the next 50 years
right it's what we are doing now are we
taking a big risk
yeah but i think that if we focus
on one thing and do that one thing
exceptionally well
we won't fail at that one thing so
sometimes you got to put the other stuff
to bed and focus on what you believe is
is uh is the core of the company and
that always starts from what you love to
do the most
my philosophy was a very simple one i um
and this is where i think film plays a
big part of my life i
you know rudy was one of my favorite
films growing up after watching that
film i come to understand
if i could work that hard every day
with the being blessed with the physical
tools that i have
what would my career be and i made a
promise to myself
from that day that i was going to work
that hard
every single day so that when i do
retire
i have no regrets and that was the most
important thing for me is to leave no
stone unturned
get better every single day and if i
live that way then
over time you know i'd have something
that was beautiful
but that was my philosophy it seems like
a pretty simple one but
you know if you live your life to just
get better every single day
and do that for 20 years i mean what do
you have what does losing feel like to
you
oh it's exciting why is it exciting
um because it means you have different
um
ways to get better there are certain
things that you can figure out
that you can take advantage of right
certain weaknesses that were exposed
um that you need to shore up right so it
was exciting i mean
it sucks to lose but at the same time
their answer is there if you just look
at them
um because you get the information from
losing more than from winning probably
yeah yeah i mean the answers are there
when you win too you you just have to
look at them
yeah right so it's a constant process
it's exciting when you win it's exciting
when you lose because the process should
be exactly the same
whether you win or you lose as you go
back and you look and you find things
that you could have done better
you find things that you've done well
that worked figure out how did they work
why did they work how can you make them
work again
yeah and uh but the hardest thing is to
face that stuff
um that's a really really tough
challenge you mean face it you mean
look yourself in the mirror and say okay
this is how i showed up or this is what
happened and i'll give you an example so
katie lou samuelson is one of the best
college basketball players in the
country she plays at uconn she's going
to be a senior
right now right now and she's from
huntington beach out here by us
and so she comes down and she works with
some of my my girls on the team and she
helps coach and yeah
and uh they just had a really tough
season last year where they lost to
notre dame in the final
that's right really tough first loss
first loss years right
and so i actually said have you watched
the notre dame game she was like
no well why not i said i don't want to
watch that i said i know you don't but
you're going to play notre dame this
year yeah yeah there's a chance that you
see him again
in the final that's well you'll probably
see me again
say well you can't show up and play them
without knowing why you lost that one
right so you know the mistakes that
you've made in that game you have to do
the hard stuff
and watch that game and study that game
to not make those mistakes over and over
again
just because you weren't brave enough to
face it so she came down to the office i
brought down the officer we sat down we
watched that game together
right you gotta you gotta deal with it
face it gotta deal with it
face it learn from it wow it must have
been cringing for her and she'd be like
oh you're playing like we could have won
all these things that's exactly it isn't
it i just did that one thing exactly if
i didn't get that foul if i was scoring
that layup
exactly right you're looking at oh
there's the mismatch oh
there's the gap you know and all those
little things and it sucks but
but you don't want to have that feeling
again do you right so you got to really
study it
face it and uh not to say you'll win the
next time you pay but you at least
you'll you'll give yourself a better
better chance here's why practice was
important to me not from
just the standpoint that i enjoyed
playing like i enjoyed being there
um i enjoy getting better
but as a leader of a team it's also your
responsibility to elevate the rest of
the guys
and but people tend to get stuck
on a lot saying okay the way to make
players better
is to pass of the ball when they're open
that's a very
trivial way to look at things what you
have to do is you have to get them
emotionally to want to be better
you want you have to get them to an
emotional space where they wake up every
morning
driven to be the best version of
themselves right
and how do you do that and in practice
for me it was a chance to drive them
to challenge them right if they're and
this is where you have to know your
teammates
because if it's late we just had a back
to back and we had practice the next day
and you show up
and guys don't feel like going through
the motions don't feel like practicing
it's important to know each and every
one of them individually
personally because then you know what
nerve to touch
some guys it's like okay come on let's
you know we can do this that'll get them
going
other guys know you got to figure out
what button to push
you know powell is always spain
if i tell them how they lost in a gold
medal to us and how they're going to
lose again
how i'm going to beat your ass in
practice just like i beat you in a gold
medal game oh that oh he would hate that
he'd hate that but that's what practice
was you have to drive him you
absolutely have to and if practice is
more intense and harder
than a game seven will be then a game
seven will be easy but if it's not
then that's when teams start folding and
capitulating if you want to change your
life
in the next 30 days for free check out
my training right here below or if you
want some more
affirmations from david goggins check
out the video right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there